Disney Disney they did it again Disney
is changing the lyrics to The Little
Mermaid
specifically the song Kiss the Girl now
I have not seen The Little Mermaid since
I was about five years old
I don't remember anything about it
really and I've never read the Hans
Christian Andersen book so I
all I remember really is that song you
got to kiss the girl I don't even really
remember where the tune goes so go on
and kiss the girl you know that song so
that's the song They're Gonna Change
and why are you know why they're going
to change it
you're not allowed to just kiss a girl
anymore
you're practically a rapist if you K if
you kiss a girl if you like a girl and
you're kind of flirting with each other
and then you lean in you know in a
little have a little smooch oh yeah so
you're not allowed to do that you need
to get written and notarized letter of
consent from her witnessed by three
different people signed off on by a
judge that's the only then maybe you can
consider
sending her a telegram to ask if she
might be willing to kiss you what are
the lyrics these are the lyrics they're
going to change
yes you want her
look at her you know you do possible she
wants you to there is one way to ask her
it don't take a word not a single word
go on and kiss the girl
this is this is an even sillier version
of the left-wing temper tantrums over
maybe it's cold outside
they say oh it's not consensual it's
rapey it's coercive it's
no it's romantic it's romantic to go off
when you're you go up and you're
flirting with the girl and you both kind
of like each other and you both kind of
lean in a little bit and then what do
you do when you Smooch
and she's like oh she likes to kiss you
or you know what maybe she doesn't like
you to kiss her and so she turns her
head away
and that smooch lands on the cheek and
you got rejected okay all right there
you go at least you tried to kiss the
girl the libs
have lost a sense of romance
that's why they don't get
kiss the girl that's why they don't get
maybe it's cold outside the whole point
of Baby it's cold as I was like oh I
really shouldn't stay but maybe it's
cold outside all right well maybe okay
I'll just stay for a little bit I guess
it's a little game of Seduction it's a
game of flirtation it's it's the the
woman because she has an ideal of
modesty she wants to stay with the guy
but she knows that she ought to be
modest and so there's like there's a
dance that's taking place there and
there's a much more innocent version of
that even taking place in
the Disney song but the libs have lost
that because they've lost the conception
of the difference between men and women
for the libs everybody is the same for
the libs everybody's just
we're all just kind of
blobs we're all sexless blobs
and so you gotta this started with
feminism but you that means you you
can't treat male female reactions as
something special and fun and coquettish
and no no it's just we're all just blob
so you should treat your romantic
partner in the same way you treat your
accountant it's completely ridiculous
and and you see the the height of this
in
yesterday's great International holiday
it was International asexuality day did
you know that asexuality which literally
means you're just not sexual
but then I saw a meme going around
they're all like these explainer memes
from the sexual Revolution and this one
it's an asexual myths here are the myths
all asexuals hate and don't want sex
and the correction is not all asexuals
feel this way okay uh myth asexuals
don't want to be in relationships
response many do
with or without sex
so not even just without sex with or
with that asexuality is a choice someone
says no you're thinking of celibacy or
abstinence we can't stop being asexual
but asexual means what does it mean it
means you either like sex or you don't
like sex and you do want to be in a
relationship or you don't want to be in
a relationship and if you are in a
relationship it's either with sex or
without sex and that's asexuality uh
no that's just anything
that's just that's just every option
so on asexuality Day we celebrate
it everything but it's supposed to be
really Niche and special
and the problem that the libs are
running into and the reason that there
are gazillion genders and the reason
that we can't pin down the meaning of
any particular concept anymore is
because
if everything means everything then
nothing means anything
nothing means anything if anybody can be
a woman then woman doesn't mean anything
if anybody can be an American American
doesn't mean anything
if any if anybody can be asexual then
asexual asexual actually does not does
not mean anything the Biden
Administration cannot win for losing
everything that Joe Biden touches turns
to Ash and even the liberal press is
noticing it
on the this was Thursday night
Thursday late afternoon there was a news
dump and the News dump was that the uh
Afghanistan withdrawal report is finally
coming out this is now long overdue and
even Ed O'Keefe at CBS News not exactly
a right-wing Outlet called out John
Kirby over at the White House and said
wait a second why why are you dumping
this report right before Good Friday
right before everyone's taking time off
for Easter this this is you're obviously
just trying to hide this
so John thank you for doing this but I
think I speak on behalf of my colleagues
in this room when we want the record to
reflect this was sent to us about 10
minutes before the briefing began with
little notice and it's the very
definition of a modern major holiday
News company releasing this uh at the
beginning of the high holidays and after
months of requests from Republicans and
the broader public
um so why today and is this all we get
and is this a response to the studies
that were done by the agencies which is
considered a summary so good on Ed
O'Keefe for calling him out like this it
obviously is a major holiday news dump
and why are they doing it it's because
the Afghanistan withdrawal was a
complete debacle it was tragic and a
huge embarrassment for the Biden
Administration and so the only option
they've got is to sweep it under the rug
that is their best bet there's no other
way yes it's embarrassing that they're
being called out for for the holiday
news dump but it's less embarrassing
than having to actually answer for this
the Biden foreign policy has been a
complete disaster and we've just heard
about this from Russia Russia is now
saying that that the U.S is in a hot war
with Russia not a cold war not a new
Cold War not a proxy war through Ukraine
Russia's saying we're in a hot War they
say quote
I think we've already passed the period
of Cold War now we are in the face of a
hot conflict with the United States we
are witnessing the direct involvement of
that country in a hybrid war with Russia
on various fronts
the way our American opponents are
recklessly provocatively and in many
respects absolutely carelessly moving up
the escalation ladder the way they are
blinded by their absolute absolutely
absurd certainty about their ability to
inflict a strategic defeat on Russia
makes one doubt they're mental faculties
in their Common Sense I've told you
before I'll say it again the best kind
of propaganda is the kind that's true
and is this propaganda yes and is it
true yes it is also I am seriously
doubting the mental faculties and common
sense of my leaders here in the United
States obviously our president barely
knows his own name and you want to talk
about their common sense they don't know
the difference between boys and girls
and men and women
and as pertains to this issue our
sclerotic Elite is sleepwalking us into
World War III
show me the lie here show me the lie
that we're in an increasingly hot war
with Russia we are
yeah that's true it's not a war that the
American people seem very much to want
but it's a war that was forced upon us
and it's been building for a very long
time
and it would be one thing if we had an
agile intelligent serious Elite that was
running the country that was waging this
war but we don't we have Joe Biden who
doesn't know what day it is we've got
Mark milley who wants to focus on white
rage and critical race theory for his
poor troops we've got we've got the
Admiral Levine assistant Secretary of
Health who says we need to trans the
kids we've got John Kirby over there a
spokesman who who is trying to cover up
all the failures of the Afghanistan
withdrawal from the political plus it's
just a complete joke and by the way
we've got Vladimir zielinski the leader
of Ukraine who says that Joe Biden
essentially caused the war is Joe Biden
pulled the pressure off of Russia in the
form of lifting those sanctions before
he reinstituted the sanctions and
because Joe Biden literally invited
Putin to invade part of Ukraine he said
if it's only a minor incursion into
Ukraine then it won't be that big of a
deal
and so what does Putin do he invades
Ukraine and now what's happening we're
just escalating this war mindlessly and
mindlessly
he's saying this is
this is increasing by the day and it is
Wars have started over a lot less hot
Wars have started over a lot less I'd
love to the Russia points out says the
Absurd certainty about America's ability
to inflict a strategic defeat on Russia
it increasingly seems like an absurd
certainty because we were told that
those those sanctions were going to
Rally the whole world we're going to
impose those sanctions on Russia who's
going to destroy the U.S economy and
what happened it basically boomeranged
back on the United States and Europe
especially Europe but it hit back on the
west
we didn't Russia we didn't end
the war it didn't work
I don't consider that a knock on the U.S
and I don't consider that something to
be admired about Russia but it sure as
hell a knock on our Elite these guys
don't know what they're doing
and now we're trusting them to what to
talk us down from World War III no way
they're going to get us into World War
III if we're not in it already and then
do you trust them to wage World War III
I don't I don't trust Joe Biden to go
buy the right ice ice cream down the
street
I don't trust him to do anything and I
don't trust his people to do anything
either the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles Canada wlas
a check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
thank you